j'ai tout de suite voulu racheter la rue
de Verneuil et racheter les meubles
pour que ça bouge pas mais c'était plus
évidemment je voulais faire un musée
parce que je me suis dit que c'est ce
que mon père aurait voulu
mais c'était je pense aussi plus
égoïstement juste pour faire comme si il
était encore là
du coup je m'y enfermé plus pour me
faire du mal mais enfin c'était la façon
j'avais pas trop
ah si j'avais le choix de pas y aller
mais mais
je pouvais pas aller au cimetière parce
qu'il y avait du monde
c'était compliqué en fait
le deuil de mon père j'ai jamais pu le
faire parce que j'ai pas pu moi mais
aussi parce que
j'étais tout le temps en réaction à ce
que les gens me
ce qui partageait avec moi ils avaient
envie de me parler de mon père qui
venait de mourir ils avaient envie de me
montrer des trucs je l'entendais à la
radio
je passais devant la rue de Verneuil
il était c'était impossible de
de se protéger en fait ce qui fait que
bon donc
j'ai pas géré j'ai pas géré ce cette
disparition le manque ça m'a
anéanti mais pendant tellement de temps
je pense jusqu'à la naissance de mon
fils j'étais dans quelque chose de très
morbide
mais bon c'était c'était comme ça on
réagit comme on peut oui et c'est vrai
que la rue de Verneuil je m'enfermais
dedans et j'avais encore l'odeur il y
avait la marque
sur son canapé comme si il y avait la
forme de son corps encore assis dessus
et il venait de mourir dans sa maison
donc sa chambre je le voyais encore
allongé comme j'ai pu le voir
continuellement donc c'est vrai que j'ai
eu un rapport quand même très très
bizarre enfin très bizarre très
particulier je pense mais voilà je suis
tellement tellement heureuse que ça je
suis heureuse et je suis très panique
mais c'est les je pense que les projets
les plus excitants et les plus forts
c'est un mélange de trouilles de
d'excitation de de bonheur quand je
quand je vois des gens y entrer parce
que moi j'ai peur encore j'ai peur que
les gens soient déçus j'ai peur que de
pas offrir assez
ce sera un petit parcours quand même la
maison est minuscule donc c'est par
petit groupe mais
j'espère que
j'offre une expérience très intime à
voilà un public malheureusement ça va
devoir s'étaler dans le temps parce que
là j'ai eu la chance de comprendre que
c'était complet jusque fin décembre
c'est les premières places qu'on a qu'on
a mis en vente après bien sûr ça va
continuer et bon j'espère que dans le
temps ça ce sera un succès en fait j'ai
pas pensé à
maintenant je me j'ai l'angoisse de
voilà il faut qu'on soit prêt déjà
et puis il faut que les retours soient
bons que ce qu'on offre en face le petit
musée le
petit café la boutique tout ça ce soit à
la hauteur de mon père parce que c'est
en fait c'est ça le l'enjeu c'est que
jusqu'à présent c'était la rue de
Verneuil que je gardais secret et tout
mais j'avais pas de compte à rendre là
j'ai quand même un compte à rendre à mon
père